- How do you know alien genetics?
- I don't know alien genetics.
Neither do you.
We're not gonna know until one of us puts
our thingy in one of their 15 holes.
- Well, you know folks,
space technology is
really advancing.
Got that nice photo of Pluto.
Found water on Mars.
We are going places, so I think we all
know we've gotta ask
ourselves one question.
Would you fuck an alien?
(upbeat music)
- If you're a consenting alien,
I would have sex with you.
- I wouldn't have sex with them.
- Pro-alien fucking.
- Team not putting my dick inside
of an alien.
- I would fuck an alien.
- I would not fuck an
unidentified foreign object.
- I would fuck an alien.
- Fucking an alien is very irresponsible.
(upbeat music)
- We've made contact with alien life.
Oh my god.
And your first response
is you wanna fuck it?
- Why not?
- There are a lot of
steps to go through before
we even consider fucking an alien.
- If they wanted to talk to us, they would
have talked to us by now,
which means they're only
coming here to do one
thing and one thing only.
- In the scenario that
aliens come to Earth and say,
"Hey, we just wanna fuck you, it's cool,"
somethings up.
- Being less intelligent
than humans, they maybe don't
understand the consequences
of possible conception,
STDs, moral and emotional consequences.
- They're obviously gonna be
more advanced than we are.
They came here, we're
certainly not going to them.
- Maybe we're going to them.
- NASA's defunded, man.
- Yeah, but space sex.
- It's true but they keep blowing up.
- When they land.
- Let's talk about the genitalia.
We don't know what they got.
- Exactly, isn't that exciting?
That's so exciting.
- They could have barbed wire dicks.
- Assuming they can wield one of these.
- Oh, wield, that sounds so violent.
- Who's to say that
alien semen isn't toxic
to human beings.
Maybe it's like fiberglass.
Maybe you won't know
until like a week later
when it itches really bad.
- Well, then you know what, Collin,
oopsy doopsy.
- I'd be very surprised if
their concept sex even involved,
um, ejaculation, right?
- Would you still feel
comfortable having sex with
a male alien or maybe a
gender non-conforming alien?
I think that that's also
something to bring up.
- It could be the kind of
thing, you know how praying
mantis have sex?
The female rips the male's
fucking head off and eats it.
- Sure, we would
communicate about this and
we'll have a safe word.
- You don't know that.
You don't know that.
- But this sounds like so much fun.
- No, because next we're
gonna talk about diseases.
- Someone has to say it, space AIDS.
- Oh yeah, you think
a condom is gonna deal
with alien pathogens?
Bullshit.
- What happens when
you get alien pregnant?
- That will be exciting.
- No, no. You don't believe that.
- So then I'm stuck with
a alien baby, literally,
and I'm starting now a new species.
- Isn't that fascinating?
- There was somebody
impregnated by an alien
that burst out of their chest.
- That's certainly a concern of mine.
- There's no way you'd ever be able to get
pregnant by something that doesn't have
the same zygotes as a person.
If a horse--
- How do you know that
they're not like, wizards?
- That's, I can't argue that.
How do you know they're not wizards?
(upbeat music)
- I think that we should be welcoming
and if they wanna have sex with me--
- Really, really welcoming.
- The first time you have sex
it's like, whoa.
This is an opportunity to
have that experience again.
- It may have been bad
to fall in love with
somebody of a different race,
creed, religious background,
in the past, but some people
broke through those barriers
and some people said, you know what?
Love is love.
- You're saying I don't
wanna be on the wrong side
of history here?
- Yeah.
- That's what the argument is?
- Yeah, because you don't
know alien and human love
could exist.
- You're the first person in the world,
you'd be the Christopher
Columbus of having
sex with aliens.
No, that's not a good
reference because Christopher
Columbus is bad.
- How do you know you haven't
had sex with an alien yet?
- I mean...
- I'm gonna have sex with it if we connect
and then I'm gonna have
the coolest, weirdest sex
imaginable and you can't
have any of it because
I'm too busy having it.
- Would you have sex with
an alien that you weren't
in love with?
- If the alien was hot.
- The fact that you're
thinking about this means
that you're imaging a sexy
alien which is fucked up
in its own right.
- No.
- What if it's just like a
ball of energy that just makes
you have the most powerful
orgasm you've ever had?
You'll never know.
- An orgasm that would be
out of this world?
- That's pretty good.
- You're just talking about
fucking him out of the gate.
Oh, this alien shows up,
it's got two legs, 15 holes,
whatever you need and then
you're gonna go for it.
- Alright, I do not need 15 holes.
I need one.
- I want to know, like, what
you think the actual sex
would be like and I need you to tell me.
- It's like every other sex.
It's about 45 seconds long
and I come at the end.
Please don't let my parents
see me say the word come.
(upbeat music)
- I wouldn't have sex
with an alien, just tell
people I had sex with an alien.
- I'm gonna do this for science.
I'm gonna do this for
exploration and I'm gonna
do this because I wanna
ride a goddamned spaceship.
- I think this just
comes down to wonderment.
- I really got too much
shit on my plate right now.
- If aliens do come to Earth,
I saw we can't trust then.
- Be adventurous.
We're young, let's live it.
- The future of the
human race is completely
dependent on us not fucking this up.
- Yeah, we might destroy the human race,
but we might destroy
the human race by coming
up with a better race.
Also, imagine me having
sex with 15 holes like
a whack-a-mole game and I think you'll
get a smile on your face.
(upbeat music)
- Maybe all aliens look like goats.
Are you gonna go fuck a goat?
- I will fuck an alien
that looks like a goat.
I need to fuck the alien
goat before I find out if
there's fiberglass in
the goat alien vagina.